e
e e
all right good afternoon everybody sorry
for the
delay uh before we get started uh can
everybody please rise for the
pledge to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
okay thank you um I will open up our
executive session for Tuesday May 7th in
Transportation uh I will announce now in
case you're here to see a couple of
these we've had a few things change uh
so we will not be taking up Senate bills
510 501 were 358 today I'm going to
reschedule those for an executive
session next
Tuesday uh so that being said um
executive session I will open up with
Senate Bill
429 relative to the color of executive
Council official cover
plates do I have a
motion representative
Hill motion is ought to pass is there a
second seconded by representative foot
you care to speak to your
motion as far as I'm
concerned as far as I'm concerned the
executive councel um can have any color
plate they want
um and that's
it and so you know they actually have
had their own color plates for quite
some time uh we don't know how it
occurred it was being done outside of
Statute so this basically brings them
back back to their blue plates that
they've had for so long um anybody else
from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role the motion on Senate
Bill 429 is ought to
pass Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative
foot yes representative C yes represent
D Simone yes representative Coker yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative St Clair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Jack yes representative
Au yes representative Jones yes
representative London yes representative
Calabro yes representative Johnson
yes is 20 to Z
19 or 20 oh oh
sorry yes sorry chairman
Walsh I shouldn't be all right our
recommendation is adopted 20 to
zero any object with no objection to
consent consent that is uh that will
close set up Bill
429 give us a moment to regroup group
and we'll get into
465 all right next up uh Senate Bill 465
relative to Motors duties When
approaching Highway emergencies
involving a stopped or standing vehicle
is there a
motion representative
Fox I move ought to pass on Senate Bill
465 okay motions ought to pass is there
a
second seconded by representative Rich
here to speak to your
motion um yes I just believe that um
this will put into statue what we assume
everybody does anyway and may not which
is um if practical give a wide birth
without endangering oncoming
traffic and uh maintain a slow
speed thank you anybody else from the
committee
really representative
Hill I maybe the only no vote on this um
I uh I think it causes more problems
than it solves I um I Envision I've seen
enough people on the highway
um
see uh a lighted vehicle and go shooting
over without looking to see who's next
to them that I can only imagine um the
same situation happen if there's an
abandoned vehicle on the side of the
road and they will come shooting over um
regardless is thinking that that's the
law so I'm not a fan um and I'll be
voting
now anybody
else represent C the only thing I noted
on this bill and it can be fixed in uh
when the bill is enrolled it's on line
nine between emergency and warning there
does not need to be a comma
there that is the type of thing that can
get fixed once it's enrolled anybody
else seeing then I I represent
Smith yeah just a question for everybody
to think about before they vote um that
this adds some pretty big impact new
language to the existing statute the the
current language is give a wide birth
without endangering blah blah blah and
this says if
practical who determines the
practicality what's the penalty and how
will that work at the court hearing and
what's the violation
anybody else and I agree I'm leaning
towards a no on this um I get it but
even during our public hearings we heard
that enforceability is going to be a
problem and if we're going to pass a l
I'd like to see it do something um
representative Hill I think his his um
his point is is valid uh being a
motorcyclist I consider that as well I
don't want to be to the left of somebody
and have somebody panic and Shoot To the
Left to make sure the around somebody
who's in the breakdown Lane
thirdly if you've got the wherewithal to
make the maneuver to
yield that means you already spotted the
person in the breakdown Lane so the
chances of hitting them are probably
pretty slim you've already spotted them
I just don't see the need for this and I
don't see what it accomplishes so I'm
leaning towards the no side anybody else
rep the of s
clear I I just try I watch people all
the time um the chair and uh it seems
like most people already kind of do that
move and and uh I agree I I think there
are some people like they do with
emergency vehicles they just freak out
and and just
overreact and and that that is a
worrisome situation thank you yeah and
again that's my point I mean a lot of
people do it most people with courtesy
and Common Sense are going to continue
to do it why do we need it instead
statute that's if it's not enforcable so
anybody
else represent SES so from my point of
view that one of the uh prime directive
for this committee is to look out for
Public Safety and the numbers of persons
who are killed or injured of the
motoring public who have pulled over as
far as they felt safe and comfortable to
do um is a staggering number um you know
it's
it it varies of course year to year I
think this is a good Public Safety
message um uh bill and I would and it
was supported by uh the New Hampshire
dot um the New Hampshire State Police
who watched traffic patterns and and the
way people uh Drive quite carefully I'm
sure and um the aaa's also had written
testimony in favor as did the prime
sponsor so for that reason and many more
I would be voting in favor of this
spell anybody
else representative Koker yeah I wasn't
going to speak on this one but you know
I think what the chairman said about
this is if people see these these people
they're going to move over or they're
not going to hit them and I think that
what I my concern with this bill is it
might give kind of a false it's kind of
safety theater it it's it's doing
something that really isn't attacking
the root cause of the problem which I
think is you know maybe we should be
focused more on like the visibility of
if you're on the side of the road you
know I mean get make yourself visible
you know like maybe we should start
really attacking that problem versus
just kind of attacking a problem that
seems to be the norm
of the average motorist so I think um
I'm gonna be a no vote on this
one anybody else represent a in Clair
last time thank you Mr chair I think
that um a lot of these accidents where
people do plowing the people on the side
of the road the law is not going to make
a difference they just didn't see them
because they weren't paying attention or
perhaps the the vehicles that are off
the side of the road either weren't off
far enough they didn't have their
flashes on they didn't put something out
I I just don't know the answer but I'm
worried about uh this this being a uh
not unenforceable but maybe being
enforced at uh opportune
times anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the rooll when she's ready
the motion is ought to pass on Senate
Bill
465 Vice chairman Gorski no
representative Smith no clerk votes yes
representative Hill no representative D
no representative FL no representative C
no representative D Simone no
representative Koker no representative
Sykes
yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair no
representative
Fox
yes representative Jack yes
representative AO yes representative
Jones yes representative LOM yes
representative cabro yes representative
Johnson yes and chairman Walsh no
gee
101 okay the motion of about the pass
fails is there a motion any other
motions representative SES I'll make a
motion of interim study
if there's that this many questions it
would be an appropriate thing to do all
right motion of inter room study
seconded by y
um I never would have expected this when
I woke up this morning but so be it um
care to speak to your
motion yeah I I think the very nature of
our vote which was 1010 which was
bipartisan there was it literally the
committee was split on what was the
right thing to do for the first motion I
suspect that there'll be split on the
SEC any subsequent motion what I'm
hoping for is that we can at least have
a majority to accept that there are
legitimate questions that should be
answered and why not take the time to
try and do that our one option to do
that is interim
study I'll agree with our ranking member
I think we had some good arguments on
both sides of this so I'll be fine with
the interim study anybody else from the
committee seeing then clerk to call the
role the motion is in room study on
Senate Bill
467 Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative FL yes
representative C yes representative D
Simone yes representative Coker yes
representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes yes
representative Jack yes representative
Au yes representative Jones yes
representative quandon yes
representative Cabra yes representative
Johnson yes and chairman Walsh yes count
zero our recommendation of interim study
is adopted 20 to zero it will close
Senate Bill
465 and uh oh um yeah without objection
ction what's
that for an interim study I don't think
that applies we'll I'll put in for it if
there's an issue they can they'll tell
me so without objection interim study it
is I mean a consent it
is
e e
all right next up um Senate Bill 467
FN authorizing the injury prevention
center to issue motor vehicle decal
plates um is there a
motion see I know you all expect me to
have somebody lined up for all these
motions and reports we're doing it a
little bit different
today was that your hand going up repes
of St Clair
no yes I'll make the motion to uh L to
pass on SP
467 yeah all right motion is to pass on
cable 467 is there a second seconded by
representative Hill care to speak to
your motion
representative I'd like to just say it's
an brainer and walk away um if uh they
feel that uh this is going to help them
raise some funds for their cause then I
think it's a good motion to
support thank you sir anybody
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the rule motion is out to pass Vice
chairman Gorski yes representative Smith
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative J yes representative
foot yes representative C
yes representative D Simone yes
representative Koker yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Jack yes representative
AO yes representative Jones yes
representative bandam
yes representative cabro yes
representative Johnson yes chairman
Walsh yes 20 to zer
recommendation our recommendation
adopted 20 to Zer I heard consent any
objection consent that is I will close
Senate Bill
467 uh a couple of minutes we're get to
Senate Bill 469
only because answer
question I'm going to switch the order
up to so you're already we do have
somebody to answer some questions so
we'll do we'll take up Center Bill 581
next
I'm
ready y
okay we're going to open up executive
session on Senate Bill 581 relative to
temporary driver's licenses and
non-driver identification cards is there
a
motion for discuss
Well
yeah if make a motion that your gut
feels we're going and you can always
change your mind if you don't like the
answer some of the
questions I'll move
um I want to say in study here I I'll
move interim
study okay motion it's a it's proper
motion interim study has been moved is
there a
second second by representative
C can speak to your motion at this point
or
you're okay no I have further questions
and I can always retract my motion okay
so we're open for discussion any anybody
from the committee you have a question
or specific like would like back to
represent me at this nobody can hear me
with my mic off so we did have a
question and I know we have somebody
from the Secretary of State's office
here can
you resmar eyesee what your questions
might have been
on on the language I believe it was on
page
two
um I can maybe jump in if you want what
Bill 581 581 I want I just wanted to be
sure that I'm on the right Bel okay so
on 581 page
two um there's a
provision uh starting on I believe it's
line 28
it says applicants whose online renewal
application is approved shall receive a
temporary proof of license which shall
constitute the applicant's valid driver
license until division issues a physical
driver license to the applicant or the
expiration of 60 days whichever
shall e
fortunately we have somebody from the
Secretary of State's office here to
answer that question it's a good
question so how do they going to know
that a temporary license is not
acceptable for voting purposes
thank you for the question uh my name is
Aon hen Hennessy I am the deputy
secretary of state I was summoned here
via email I didn't know what your
questions were going to be so I
apologize for not being prepared I'm
happy to get you answers to that we do a
lot of training in the Secretary of
State's office um I believe right now
there may already be some of that
language in current law that ISS not
valid for voting purposes and the reason
is is that a driver's license doesn't
constitute proof of US citizenship even
the um even the the new one the real ID
thank you sorry transportation is not my
wheelhouse um does that answer your
question we we do a lot of training with
the election officials about
this it perplex your answer actually
perplexes me even more because I I see
that
on Election Day you walk into a room
they want to see your driver's
license I renewed my driver's license
and I had a paper driver's license at
one time showed them that they handed me
my ballots and off I
went so it concerns me that these
volunteers may not be as well trained as
the supervisors of the checklist would
be trained because all they are is
people who sit at a desk check your name
off hand you the ballots and have a nice
day that's my
concern so you're talk thank you for the
question so you're concerned that the
ballot clerks who are not elected
officials who are appointed would not
understand so to in order to get a
ballot from them you already have to be
on the checklist so what they're looking
for is your just to identify that you
you are the person who you say you
are follow up y thank you so if I go in
and I don't have proof of residency I
can go in a room and I can fill out a
piece of paper that says that I'm
legally able to vote and take both of
both my temporary license and that piece
of paper and nobody's really knowing the
difference it's just my concern
because ethical people would never do
such a
thing but we're not always dealing with
ethical people and that's my
concern thank you I didn't hear much of
a question there on the last one but so
my question is how do we prevent that
from happening with people who are not
necessarily trained as well as
supervisors of the checklist and they're
just clerks how do we prevent
that thank you for the question so I'm
not sure if this is the answer you're
looking for but there are there's two
different processes one the registration
process where you can use affidavits or
actual document proof for your residency
your age your identity and your
citizenship if you are already on the
checklist then you need to just show
proof of ID to get your Ballot or an
election official can identify you as
being who you say you are if they know
you or you can use an affidavit to say
who you are well that raises the
question for me and I think that's maybe
where we're getting we all know we go
into to vote I give my driver's license
to the clerk she goes down the checklist
I'm in the W's and I get my ballot and
off I go this says what if I had what if
I what if I was able to temporary
license can I still do the same process
with the clerk with my temporary license
or does some of the process need to
happen can you point me to the language
you're looking at specifically anybody
have a copy of the bill they can share
with
her and we're looking on page two lines
one through four
actually pleas reading go ahead
y are you are you asking the the
checklist versus registering to vote is
that what no I'm I'm asking is that what
you're asking the bill States the way
it's written that a temporary
license is
not um sufficient proof for voting
purposes so a temporary license as we
learned at the last hearing is nothing
more than a copy of your new one but you
just haven't got your real card yet and
I'm just questioning the fact that
because it's temporary and it says in
this bill that you can't use it for
voting purposes what is the next step so
you you can't use it to identify
yourself because you can't you can't
register with it because you need more
documents than then Ser driver's license
your I'm asking you is so it's the way
it reads is that I can't use this to
identify myself to say who I am for the
checklist okay
so the way the way so I apologize this
was not on my radar of bills that I was
supposed to be looking out for
um the way I read it is and I'm not a
lawyer is that you would not be able to
check in to get your ballot if you had a
temporary driver's license however
there is another law that says that you
can use an expired driver's
license and there's there's a law around
the and I I
apologize if if I I would have done
brought all the laws um with the with
the exceptions um and how long it can be
um expired for um but I do see the issue
with the language here and and maybe
it's to register to vote I'm not sure
what the intention of that language was
in the bill
representative C and thank you very much
we I know we're throwing you to the
Wolves all right thank you Mr chairman
thank you uh secretary for taking the
question I see two issues here one is if
you're just coming into the state and
getting a new license you've gone to the
registry you've turned in your old
license and they give you a little piece
of paper that you can fold the other one
is which I've just done because my
license expires in May is I went online
I still have my old license but they
gave me a thing to print
out uh that I can carry with me that
lets if the state please call pull me
over it lets them know that I've applied
for the thing and haven't gotten it in
the mail um so I I see that
as uh and what you just pointed out is
my old license is good enough for
identification even if it's
expired there are there are limitations
on the time frame for it I believe but I
have to I have to get all the election
law is very complicated
followup yeah go ahead follow up um just
as a followup is this something that
should have been included in the
election law sections rather than just
in the driver's license sections thank
you for the question I think I think
that would be a great idea to include it
in the election law section
um because then it would have gone to
election law for voting purpose for for
the um discussion on this because they
are they have the background in this not
saying that you guys don't have the
background in this since you are elected
but
um I know that you want to EXA this
today I'm happy to get some more
questions answered from my legal staff
if you're would like that um I think the
reason why I didn't know about this is
because it came to transportation and
not to election law in either of
the well we are the driver's license
specialist right I
[Laughter]
know um representative
S I don't actually thank you uh Senator
Hennessy I appreciate you being here
today um I don't actually have a
question for you but I have a question
for the chair
um part of the problem that I'm
struggling with is that the purpose of
this bill is to get people who come in
and getting their driver's license they
can't get the actual PL I'll call it the
plastic one that we normally have to
give them something to drive in case
they get stopped that's the
purpose and I worry that we are um
conflating some issues towards other
matters that don't more properly belong
before another committee and I wonder my
question to you Mr chair is if you can
recess this until the Secretary of
State's office has an opportunity to to
weigh in on this a little bit
more that's where I was headed
representative 6 as we do as I stated
earlier are coming back next Tuesday uh
so I will recess this and and reschedule
it for that
date any other questions for
now Jack uh thank you Mr chairman uh one
of the things I don't remember from last
if I go in in person what I don't
remember is if they take the plastic
license and give you the paper or if you
get to keep both and if you get to keep
both then you still have the plastic
license you could use for this expired
license potentially it could expire
before you get the new one then you
still have the plastic license you could
use uh for the checklist but it would be
good to get that answer uh the answer is
you do get your old one back when it's
expired actually usually wrap the new
one around it um but that's where we're
at in this
bill even according to the secretary of
state that the expired ones are not oh
no you can use them according to what
she stated but then then Roman 4A says
that you can even with having the
expired one so let's get we we're going
to come back one more time let's get
some of these answer questions answered
um I see a couple more representative
Hill do you need me to withdraw my
income study
motion yeah I'm not sure to recess to
recess
no I'm just asking
is s another is s another question down
here oh not a question just to answer uh
representative Jack I just got a new
license when they fold the paper one
around it they cut the corner of the
expired one so there is a way of knowing
it's expired so just a little just to
add represent C uh if if it all possible
if if uh we need an amendment we should
have some information before next
Tuesday
absolutely chairman yep should I work
with someone on your committee for that
Amendment language if it's needed yes
and I will I'll get that designate okay
all right thank you very much for coming
on short notice too by the way um with
no other questions I'm going to recess
the executive session on Senate Bill 469
no four 581
sorry and I will reschedule that for
next two
Tuesday all right now we will move into
as soon as the clerk's ready sent up
Bill
469 e
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session at Senate Bill 469 which is
relative to allowing surveillance of the
park and right facility in circum
certain
circumstances is is there a motion
second call for any motions on Senate
Bill
469 representative
pondon I move to recommend OTP for
Senate Bill
469 motion is ought to pass it there
second seconded by representative Rich
car to speak to your motion sir thank
you Mr chair um this is legislation on
um private uh parck and ride facilities
that are Leasing
um or operating on behalf of the
Department of uh Transportation so again
it's a it's a private entity um these
pack and rides uh in recent Years or or
even have had a lot of crime Smash and
grabs uh there's also been a lot of uh
U how can I say U fonus uh activity that
and and these security cameras are part
of our society now and again to
emphasize it's privately owned so I
don't think this is going to be the big
brother syndrome so I would recommend uh
on to pass thank you Mr
chair thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee representative Hill thank you
um they aren't privately owned um these
are these are still State own properties
I believe um that are proper and and the
private entity is leasing the property
from from the state um for me there's
still questions um I know when the state
owns property there are limitations on
the amount of time that uh surveillance
tapes can be used Allah um
representative Kirk rule um and most
people are nodding that no
representative Kirk um I'm not
sure and I don't believe this if this
passes that those uh time limits for the
storage of these surveillance tapes
applies and that leads to me another
question of whether uh those storage
tapes would then be available as kind of
an end around around the Restriction
that we have on government property and
the and the limitations on those um
storage tapes so I um for that reason
and I will not support the
bill representative
blondon thank you
um to what we had for a discussion in
our prior meeting uh this is for nine
facilities and that the stored materials
are held for 24 days um I work at
Hillsboro County Superior South we have
cameras everywhere and you see a lot of
State facilities there's cameras outside
of all of our buildings here in conquer
this is not uh an unknown issue of
surveillance to try to capture evidence
of uh violations be it personal or
property uh and obviously our men and
women in blue can't be everywhere so
that's why we need the eyes of
surveillance so again I was just to my
note the uh stored materials are for 24
days is that's what came up in
discussion thank you repr st cair thank
you Mr chair I just you know these are
public facilities I don't know how much
privacy we need in a public facility I'm
on the public we're all on the
public hav't been uh victimized by crime
or know of other people or come upon a
scene where there's been a crime usually
the first thing people ask
cameras so we can see who did this and
have a chance at getting maybe some
justice there and I uh know that just in
the last weekend we had a bunch of uh
cars broken into with the uh Trail heads
that are public facilities that people
want to feel safe leaving their vehicles
there when they hike up a trail or visit
the park or whatever this is
um 24 days or a year I don't care you're
in public you're in public it's not in
my driveway where I probably expect a
little bit of
privacy it's in a public facility and
that's what these cameras do is they add
a a little bit of a level of hopefully
protection from deterring somebody to
break in or at least make them put a
hood on or something like that but it
gives it gives us it gives law
enforcement and it gives us as Citizens
a chance to maybe get back a little bit
of Justice yeah thank
you um representative Gorski I just want
to mention to the committee members too
that we do have somebody from the dot
that came here specifically to answer
any questions we may have on this bill
just to let you know representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman um you know
I came today's session I actually flew
out of Nashville this this
morning and I did do a parking ride down
in
Massachusetts and when I drove my car up
I could see that there There Was You
Know camera surveillance there which
made me feel a little bit more
comfortable leaving my car there for an
extended period of time I share
representative Hill's concerns however I
think having some type of surveillance I
think helps our constituency so I'm
going to be voting for this
bill representative
cro I Le some Market in nsha and um in
it there are seven
cameras um it isn't my property I lease
it but I had to turn it over to the
police when I saw a crime against a
child that was ad adjudicated on
Thursday when we were in General Session
they pled out and that crime has you
know been rewarded basically with
Justice it was a camera I put them there
in every single room it says cameras are
here because I'm trying to prevent
people from doing things I'm trying to
prevent theft from my employees I'm
trying to record if somebody got hurt
but I turned it over to the police and I
only keep that stuff for 24 hours not 24
days so I'm just saying I felt like I
had a right to protect my property that
I'm
leasing represent Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman I just point out to the
committee uh the end of line six it says
that these cameras are not limited to
the surveillance parameters that were
negotiated with representative Kirk as
to where the images would go how long
they were kept just so everyone is clear
uh there would be as I read this there
would be no limitation on how long the
the video could be kept or who it could
be given to just so everyone is is clear
before they
vote represent
Smith thank you Mr chair um I'm not sure
that we debating the bill the the bill
is not about whether or not surveillance
is good or bad or if we should have it
or not um this is so the idea of us
being resistant to having it in the
first place is rooted in the drive
Privacy Act which is the most fiercely
guarded and protected bipartisan
legislation ever passed by the New
Hampshire house the original sponsors
were Senator Peter Burling from
Claremont representative Neil Kirk and
representative Susan Aly
since that happened we moved on to also
making sure that the government couldn't
spy on you in other ways and we had a
bill what eight years ago about the New
London rest area the issue there wasn't
whether or not Highway the surveillance
of the rest area was good or bad but
right now dot is the only one allowed to
view the
feeds this would change that the debate
then was whether or not the New London
Police Department could view the feeds
that failed um because people were
comfortable with the current system this
bill is about private legal entities who
are not government agents which is a
huge distinction in many things that we
do being the ones to run this and have
access to it so what we should de be
debating is not whether or not we want
the surveillance but whether or not we
want private companies who we don't know
I don't know where they're from who
their people are to be the ones in in
charge of the video surveillance that
they will own it right they could record
it this doesn't prohibit that so I'm not
advocating either way just let's make
sure that we're considering this bill
which is to give this access to unnamed
private legal entities at some point in
the future beyond your
control thank you for that which was
leading me to my question I was going to
call in her but maybe you know the
answer why do we have a differentiation
any idea between what the state can do
with this data versus a private
entity thank you for the awkward
question Mr
chair um so said we were moving away
from the bill get you back so right
right
now a good friend from where is looking
at the sky nervously wondering if
satellites are photographing his house
um
the idea that we can just set stuff up
and then do violations by remote control
was one fear that these surveillance
systems if networked properly could be
used to track somebody's progress and
they can it's done very effectively in
other states to run people down um
fleeing per I mean I'm okay with using
every tool we have to get some dirt bag
who kidnapped a child or something but
that is big policy that we should not
pass lightly so leaving it in the hands
of the government doing it keeps it
within your
control you give that up when you hire
private entities to do it because a
contract is going to be written and of
you know what's in the contract nope and
you never will probably so like that's
the place you have to have your head
when you decide if you're for or against
this and again I'm not advocating for or
against the bill I just want to make
sure that the actual question in the
bill which has nothing to do with
whether or not you want surveillance or
not but the actual question do you want
private entities to have this resource
and power that that's the question you
answer when you cast your
vat anybody else from the committee
representative St Clair thank
you I'm at a storage facility up in
Guilford quite regularly they have
cameras everywhere I know they're
recording them I I pay to park some of
my vehicles there kind of a little bit
like a park right I guess I don't care
that it's privately owned I don't think
any citizens care if it's privately
owned if they're getting some sense of
protection and I'm not doing anything
wrong if they want to look at me getting
in my car for the next two years it's
okay I just want some protection and I
think this allowing these private
entities to do that I our constituents
are not going to have a problem with
that thank you
anybody
else represent
cabal I got the impression that there
was suggestions that people who had won
contract with the government to lease
the properties that they may be doing
the ferious things with these
cameras I would think they've been
scrutinized quite a bit before they won
that contract I don't think they're
going to take information and and abuse
it I don't remember hearing that said
but if you
have did you something more specific did
you are you saying that's what was said
or question it was suggested by
representative Smith that that we can't
trust these um private entities um these
are largely things like
ADT um or these um facilities that have
bid for the the right to lease the
properties they've gone through
incredible
scrutiny well I don't I'll let him
respond Pres
I would never say something like that in
committee what I did say was you don't
know what the terms of the contract are
and that is a fact you will not know
what the terms of the contract are just
like legislation you may like the
language you may object to the language
strongly you don't get that opportunity
with the contract when you cast your
vote today that's all I'm saying and the
other thing I'm feeling like is we're
still on the debate of surveillance good
protects me want more of it
you know that's not happening with this
bill there will be no more surveillance
than we have right now because if you
read the statute that this bill is
amending where they can do this is
explicitly stated and I mean in detail I
93 exit 2 and sale on my 93 Exit 4 in
London there there there's a list the
way to get more surveillance is to add
things to that list this bill is simply
saying do doesn't have to do it anymore
we can hire outside contractors to do it
that is that is what the bill I'm sorry
if I'm sounding frustrated but that that
is the entire scope of the bill if you
want to take the existing surveillance
no more not one more camera because
you're not voting on that today and say
dot doesn't have to do it anymore they
can just hire some private contractors
to do it that is the bill and it isn't
that I don't trust them it's that I
don't know what those terms are going to
be when I cast my votes
today all right I think we've had just
about enough fund with 469 but I'll give
you one more stab at it representative
C okay thank you Mr chairman and this
question may be for the person from do
is are these particular facilities under
surveillance cameras now without this
bill briefly sure or just shake your
head yes or
no
yes okay anybody else from the
committee seeing none
oh what's that me yes they are being
done currently correct right and as it
was said these are already spelled out
in a statute that this bill is
amending did you have a
question well I'm going to call a
question only because you haven't said a
word all day I'll give you
one my question is for the the D
represent if you don't
mind and uh thank you for taking the
question Mr chairman thank you um well
hold on if she can introduce herself for
the question yes for the record my name
is Shelley Winters I'm the director of
the division of Aeronautics Rail and
Transit at the Department of
Transportation thank you director wers
thank you for taking my question maybe
we've asked this before but why is it
exactly does the do want this
legislation as
written the legislation as written is
very prescriptive in which ations that
would apply to that currently have fixed
route bus services with hundreds of
thousands if not millions of New
Hampshire um patrons going through there
we're looking at this to allow the
Private Industry who manages these Park
and Ride facilities and facilitates
transportation services to do Safety and
Security to Industry standards to allow
the release process to be quicker and
more effective by local law enforcement
or State Police going directly to the
facility instead of having to come to
conquer and pull images off the
transport ation Management Center
instead of having to have a state
employee intervene and physically go
pull that data and give it to um law
enforcement and it allows software
upgrades and Technology upgrades to be
done by that contracted facility manager
whose contract will go through a
governor and counsel process as opposed
to going through the state process of um
bidding things out or buying off a state
contract and and having Antiquated
technology replacing um what's currently
in there for infrastructure
did that answer your question anybody
else seeing none last clerk to call the
rooll when she's ready the motion is
ought to pass on Senate
Bill
469 Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative
Smith
no clerk votes yes representative Hill
no representative
D yes representative fo yes
representative C yes representative D
Sone yes representative
Koker um
no representative
Sykes yes representative Ridge yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Jack yes representative AU yes
representative Jones yes representative
clondon yes representative Calabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh
no
164 okay so our recommendation of to
pass is adopted 16 to4 regular calendar
it will be that closes the exec session
on Center Bill
469 and we will get
[Music]
into 582 in a moment
all right I'm going to open up the
Senate Bill
582 relative to providing an alternate
address to the Department of Motor
Vehicles is there a
motion representative Coker I'll make a
motion of a to pass a to pass is moved
is there a second second seconded by
representative Gorski care to speak to
your motion sir just makes sense um
people Snowbird going and out of the
state um having an alternate address
with the Department of Motor Vehicles
can help prevent some uh just lost mail
and make things a little bit convenient
for everybody so we should out to pass
anybody
else I think to me it made sense when I
when I realized or was uh reminded that
everything the Department of Motor
Vehicle sends out is do not forward so
if you happen to be gone for a while
you're not getting it and then the
search is on so this does make some
sense with no other comments I'll ask
the clerk to call the role when she's
ready motion as o
pass Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes Clerk yes
representative Hill yes J yes
representative yes representative C yes
representative D Simone yes
representative Coker yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Jack yes representative Veo yes
representative Jones yes representative
blondon yes representative cabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh yes 20 to Z our recommendations
adopted 20 to
Z I heard consent move without objection
consent that is I'll close
582 and last one for the day in a moment
sent a bill 598
okay all right we'll take up Senate Bill
598 our most controversial bill of the
Year requiring funeral procession lead
vehicles to obey yield signs so I have a
motion moved by representa pondon
represent London move to the pass thank
you a the pass is there a second
representative by representative St
Clair care to speak to your motion sir
uh yes I actually drafted the original
legislation and with the house reps and
Senators on the uh uh original
legislation on funeral processions with
the size of the signage of flags the
purple lights and all of that now
I that was probably
eight years ago 10 years ago and in that
time frame I have not heard of any
issues although around the state I
understand like we onen there's a lot of
roundabouts but to my understanding the
lead vehicle has always followed the uh
uh the rule of of the road you know
yielding and stop signs and then the
procession follows through uh if that
was admitted in the original legislation
then it got lost in the translation
somewhere but that this legisl
uh was fully intended when it was
originally drafted so I would recommend
a to pass just as a house cleaning
measure thank you anybody
else seeing then I'll ask the clerk to
call the rooll which she ready motion on
sen 598 is ought to
pass Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yep representative
de yes representative po yes
representative C yes representative D
Simone yes representative Coker yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative sinair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Jack yes representative be yes
representative Jones yes representative
Pon yes representative cabro yes
representative Johnson yes and chairman
Walsh yes 20 to zero uh recommendations
adopted 20 to zero hot to
pass what's that oh yeah I heard move
move consent uh without objection
consent that is I'll close the executive
session on Senate Bill
598 uh that concludes the executive
session on the bills we're going to
cover today so we've still got
510 581 501 and 358 for next week I'll
reschedule those they will be in the
calendar
uh again 581 has been recessed but I I
will
reschedule um next week we will be doing
a
morning uh exec session as opposed to
afternoon if that works for
everybody um what's up morning yeah yeah
um I'll try not to make it too early uh
any other questions or anything for the
good of the
cause oh yes please I've got a couple
new ones if you may the motion I do need
a report from you for the calendar uh
you can either do it hard copy I've got
copies or do it electronically and send
it to my legislative account your call
but I could really use them at look at
you by before by the end of the day
so all good all right thanks very much
we're jined